being from agregat background I know the
real pain points of the Farmers on daily
basis so making their lives easier is
not my dream it's my duty I'm using the
knowledge of blockchain technology that
I learned from the course to make an app
designed especially for Farmers
community and this newly learned skill
has also got me a new clients and my
yearning have increased to 80% hey I'm
gopa jambulingam I live in Chennai with
my joint family parents siblings and my
wife and my cute Oney old Prince JG moit
my family is a family of farmers I have
basically grown up on a farm I was
growing up I noticed that it is very
difficult to deal with the mediators so
I wanted to bridge the gap between
farmers and marketers that's when I came
up with this idea of form to Plate
ancestor agree chain it deals with the
streamlining the whole supply chain for
both
parties I want to build an application
for the same I realized that to do so I
needed to have enough knowledge of
blockchain Technology I have learned
professional certificate program from
blockchain from IAT kpur offered by
simply learn I'm using it to build my
app and website in fact my app is 60%
done now I also provide blockchain
consultency I was able to create an
immutable supply chain for my clients
which is helped them streamline their
business operations the course helped me
to get more clients and my earnings
increased to 80% I want to see my
company grow and bring change in the
world recently I collaborated with the
Hyderabad Agriculture University to
create agriculture waste to
biodegradable alternative for single use
packaging with less carbon emission I
got a 25 lakh rupees Grant from the
central government scheme called rkv
raar scheme from the University I
believe in that notion that knowledge
Grows by sharing so I teach students
about artificial intelligence and M
marathan course which I hold webinars
and take live classes myself I have
trained around 37,000 students so far I
believe that when you uplift others you
are in a way of uplifting yourself so
never give up keep up
Skilling